the time span that I'd like to talk
about today is this century basically to
the extent possible and not ridiculous
whoa I'd like to talk about what I call
the deep forces of globalization
probably less tendentious Lee called the
age of convergence what I basically mean
by this is that the modern economic era
began 200 years ago with the Industrial
Revolution and with industrialization
for the first 150 of the last 200 years
there was a pretty deep process of
divergence between the industrialized
and the non-industrialized that is the
gap of economic output the military
power that went along with it the
geopolitical power that went along with
the military power all was a widening
gap and of course the leaders in that
process both in the industrialization
and the military force projection and in
the geopolitical hegemony was the North
Atlantic the United States and Western
Europe I believe in the last 50 years
that process is now fundamentally
changed to a process of convergence
rather than divergence and that what's
happened is that the mechanisms that
triggered this extraordinary run of
economic development absolutely
unprecedented in human history before
1800 are now a worldwide possession so
that China and India and Southeast Asia
and Brazil and soon I believe Africa can
also experience the rapid economic
development and by virtue of the fact of
catching up which is the crucial idea
that it's economics is a lot about
technology and economic develop
is a lot about adopting technologies
that are already available from
technology leaders but have not yet
diffused to technology followers thus
giving the opportunity for a very quick
catching up by virtue of that catching
up process the gap between the rich and
the poor will narrow and the most
dramatic aspect of that is the rise of
China because that's 1.3 billion people
because the per capita income though
hard to measure with precision is rising
probably at 8 to 10 percent per year
because by the rule of 70 that means
that the doubling time is 70 divided by
8 which is a little bit less than 9
years or 70 divided by 10 which means a
7 year doubling time which means we've
got an extraordinary process of catching
up underway compared to the growth rates
of the US economy in per capita terms
which are about 2% per year a doubling
time of 35 years so I believe that we've
changed from a period of divergence to a
period of convergence I'll say a little
bit more why in just a few minutes the
second fundamental driver is the
continuing explosion of the number of us
human beings on the planet the rate of
that explosion has slowed considerably
but the absolute increases of the human
population on the planet continue to be
very significant about 85 million
population increase every year adding a
full Germany every year to the world's
population this is taking place now
mainly in the poorest countries of the
world that's where the population growth
rate
so the highest but in a world economy of
open borders mass migration and all the
rest the consequences are felt
everywhere the projections are that what
went from a population of roughly 1
billion around 1830 to 2 billion in 1930
and then very fast increments 2 3 4 5 6
billion and now it's about 13 years to
add a billion though it's gradually
slowing we're on a trajectory to reach
about 9 billion people by the year 2050
under current trends there's nothing
inevitable about the exactitude of those
trends to be sure and one of the things
that I'll come back to say is that I
think we ought to do is try to achieve a
voluntary slowdown faster so that the
population only reaches about 8 billion
people in the world rather than 9
billion a certain amount is inevitable
increase right now just from the
momentum of the young population in the
poor countries growing up to be parents
and that is going to increase by sheer
momentum a population of another billion
or so barring disaster but we have some
choices no matter what actually happens
the likelihood is the planet gets a lot
more crowded and each of those people
being born naturally wants and expects a
full life and that means a full material
life as well and that means all of the
amenities of modern technology and that
leads to the third point a fundamental
driver and that is that when you combine
the now near universality of economic
development that alludes roughly about a
fifth of the world or a sixth of the
world
covers now roughly 80% of the world and
alludes the part that I talk about in my
book the end of poverty that's the focus
is on the Neva on the bottom poorest
part but for most of the world there's a
lot of progress and there are a lot more
people when you combine those two facts
what we have is a world economy of
unprecedented scale that means use of
resources land water fossil fuels
hunting fishing clearance of land and so
forth and a scale never before
experienced on the planet likely to
become even more intense in its effects
on the planet in the next 40 or 50 years
today Al Gore received the Nobel Prize
for for his work on on climate change
and the point about climate change is
very simple to put which is that if we
just continue what we're doing now same
population same fossil fuel-burning we
would wreck the planet by the end of the
century if not sooner but we're not on a
path to do just what we're doing the
path that we happen to be on is a path
which could raise by a factor of between
3 & 6
the amount of energy we use by
mid-century which means that if you
think it's bad now the normal growth
built into this age of convergence
combined with the population increase
coming means that the burden of human
activity on the physical environment is
going to multiply tremendously from an
already unsustainable rate so we really
have our work cut out for us it's not
good enough to just run and stand in
place in other words not even good
enough just to
try to hold the line on carbon emissions
that won't do we have to somehow combine
economic growth with a reduction and a
sharp reduction of human emissions of
carbon dioxide and other human effects
on the physical earth and all when I
come back to this I'll give a name which
I really like christened by Paul Crutzen
a Nobel laureate in chemistry who was
one of the discoverers of the ozone
depletion effect and he calls our age
the age of the Anthropocene
you know the geologists have the
Pleistocene and the Holocene the ice age
and the post ice age and he said we
moved from what a geologist would call
the Holocene our current interglacial to
what he calls the Anthropocene meaning
that the real driver of the physical
earth now is people not the declared not
not the orbit of the earth which is the
main driver of the ice age cycles so he
says it's the human age the Anthropocene
which now dominates and it's a very
potent observation and we're obviously
completely unequipped for it right now
the news has not reached the White House
yet about the Anthropocene and it will
have to reach the ears of the next
president because this president won't
get it before January 20th 2009 and then
he can read about it in his spare time
and the the last fundamental driver
which I think is quite interesting is
the idea that while in general I'm a
kind of economic optimist because I'm a
believer in technology as being the
basic driver of economic improvement and
I'm a big believer that technology is
ideas and I'm a big believer in the
spread
of ideas so for me it all comes down to
the fact that technology's good ideas
and good ideas can be shared can be
absorbed and therefore whatever good
ideas richworld has can be in some way
under appropriate circumstances useful
to the poorer world and thereby have a
broad-based economic progress there are
places on the planet that are not part
of that process and in category four I
use this tendentious name that's used
failed States that technically really
should be reserved for the government
structures of societies where government
can't perform its core functions of
being the legitimate monopoly of
violence for example or the locus of law
these are places like Somalia for
instance where there is no rid of the
state or places in civil war or places
that are so impoverished that even if
there is a political unity and even
intentionality of government there's
often no means to carry out the most
basic services of commercial law or
provision of infrastructure or Disease
Control and these places could be called
generally failed States now we've always
had state failure for all of human
history what's different now well one
thing is probably they're fewer failed
States so that's the good news but on
the other hand what's also different now
is that disasters that befall a failed
state can have worldwide repercussions
fairly easily and I always do think if I
were asked on September 10 2001 not
perhaps not knowing just on basic
principles choose a place in the world
least likely to bother us here probably
I would say on general geographical
principles I'll take the center
of the Eurasian landmass I mean how
could Kabul bother us and of course 9/11
among many other things was a what was a
an attack inflicted by a base of
operations in Afghanistan and that means
that there is really no connection on
the world no such thing as the place
that is a place that is just too far a
way to care about that's true not only
in the humanitarian sense it's true in
the political sense very real political
sense it's also true in the public
health sense and in others as well
diseases that can absolutely ruin your
day like AIDS started in a jungle in
West Africa so why the hell should we
care about a chimpanzee hunter in the
West African rainforest well it turned
out because the ZOA notic disease that
went from that chimpanzee to the human
and then spread around the world has now
infected 40 million people and claimed
several million deaths a year so there
is no sense of an isolated place anymore
and that's why I think we do that's in a
sense always been a surprise and true
and why would a gunshot in Sarajevo
start the worst war in our history and
or the most the biggest upheaval and it
does but here it's even more remote and
less likely and less understood places
and again I think our politics are very
poorly considered for all of this so
these are the four drivers that I think
are critical the four drivers being
convergence demography ecosystem
pressures and inter-linkages
on the downside meaning that your system
better function pretty resilient lien
robustly and you better avoid accidents
and care about them in the end how does
one address these concerns beyond
analysis and what I'm going to argue is
that all of these are to an extent under
human control if you will they're all
politically mediated phenomena we have
choices on all of them and the choices
are going to make a great deal of
difference so stepping back trying to
see the big picture of the underlying
tectonics that are shaping the world and
then understanding what are the risks of
earthquakes that are coming from this is
quite useful because we're not simply
spectators in these events we can
actually take political decisions
there's a problem though that I think is
a logical corollary of this way of
thinking which is that the political
decisions we need to take are more
global than ever in other words we
really need global decision-making we're
not so great at that either you probably
noticed but since you're going to be the
ones making the global decision-making
in the future it's worth you're trying
to figure out how to do it I think that
most of these issues cannot be solved on
a national level the most preposterous
thing in the world is the United States
trying to act unilaterally this is just
an absolutely poor diagnosis of the
underlying drivers it's thinking 19th
century thinking in the 21st century it
wouldn't even have worked in the 20th
century but it definitely is the 19th
century thinking in couple centuries
late so maybe George Bush would have
been a good sheriff in Texas in 1840 but
he's from my point of view an absolutely
miscast president in the 21st century
this style of foreign policy is
completely different from what you need
if you're taking the global shapers as
as the main drivers of politics so let
me say a few words about each of these
and I'm going to try to stop at 5:15 and
you're going to have lots of arguments
and questions ready and then we'll spend
at least a half an hour or 45 minutes
discussing those so the first point is I
want to divide the world little
artificially but I think helpfully into
an age of divergence and an age of
convergence and I'm putting the
breakpoint at 1950 and by this I'm
taking an economic perspective where I'm
arguing that the gaps of between rich
and poor widened significantly in the
first two centuries of the Industrial
Revolution a few minutes ago I called it
a hundred fifty years actually the steam
engine was invented around 1719 but it
wasn't very functional by 1750 had been
improved a bit England was beginning its
industrialization in the second half of
the 18th century but just England it's
really in the beginning of the 19th
century that the concepts of the
Industrial Revolution take off and
mainly at the end of the Napoleonic Wars
from then until the end of the Second
World War I would claim there was
basically divergence in the world
economy with one huge exception so the
divergence was that the North Atlantic
and a couple of other settler sites
which are from a demographic point of
view minor but from a political and case
perspective interesting and that's
Australian New Zealand aside from a few
places the North Atlantic Oceania and
Japan this was an era where the rest of
the world was on the receiving end of
industrialization and the real
industrial
icers were the United States and Western
Europe in essence and the rest of the
world got some industry but mainly it
got conquered by those who got industry
and I believe that there were
essentially these three forces of
divergence that were important at the
time a concentration of technological
capacity that's if I were a historian
I'd say Sachs you're all wrong it goes
back 300 years before that it doesn't in
economic terms but it might in
explaining the Industrial Revolution but
whatever it is there was a concentration
of technological capacity that was
pretty much unique in the world
in Western Europe and in the United
States and then only Japan as a country
that developed this capacity as a
follower country in the 19th century ii
was resource endowments the key to
success in the 19th century one key was
you had to have coal if you didn't have
coal forget it
you needed coal because the motive force
of the Industrial Revolution was the
steam engine and then at the end of the
19th century through science and
technology it was learned how to
mobilize water power for
hydroelectricity and how to use
petroleum in internal combustion but
before that it was coal and that was a
fundamental driver of industrialization
if you look at where the coal deposits
are they're not in Africa and they're
not in most of South America and they're
not in much of Asia but they are a bit
in Japan some in China I a lot in Russia
all through Western Europe and the
United States and that made a big
difference and then at least in a very
simple little bit cartoonish but I think
accurate way
this burst of technological innovation
combined with the energy base which was
the fundamental resource need for
industrialization energy fossil fuel
gave such an advantage of military power
that it led to an enormous explosion of
conquest there was already colonial rule
all through the Indian Ocean and on the
margins of Africa but with the
Industrial Revolution this became
wholesale takeover and that definitely
widened the gap still further because
was almost impossible to achieve
industrialization under colonial
domination because the colonial system
of every imperial power was designed to
hinder or at least not give any basic
support to the industrial process but
mainly to extract raw materials for the
home country and so the political
dominate and certainly not to educate
anybody or almost anybody but a very
very thin indirect rule class in
colonial countries and so from my point
of view this was a major amplifier of
this initial takeoff so an initial
takeoff of Europe followed by the
Imperial era was a widening still of the
gap between those who did industrialize
and those who didn't and the receiving
end of this was pretty painful it was
conquest it was a lot of exploitation a
lot of being on the receiving end of a
tremendous racist ideology for two
centuries and very hard to develop and
so I completely reject the idea of Neil
Ferguson at Harvard for example that
Empire was the these were the pipes of
modernization
he's written praise of empire how the
British Empire modernized the world
nonsense in my view it was much better
thank you if England had stayed there we
could have traded it would have been
much better and you didn't need empire
for modernization Japan was a very good
example of watching learning responding
out of fear of course it was the fear of
conquest that led to the Meiji
Restoration in 1868 and that set off the
trigger of modern development but it was
Japan sovereignty that enabled
industrialization to take hold so what
happened well a couple of things happen
first fundamentally fundamentally
economic development is based on ideas
even more than it's based on coal coal
is important but it turned out coal was
just one of many motive forces oil
turned out to be useful eat more easily
transportable natural gas other sources
of power hydro electricity and so on you
can actually trade for energy so you
didn't have to own it after a while
ideas matter fundamentally literacy
spread and Europe went into a paroxysms
of self annihilation in two world wars
and Great Depression and without that
probably that Imperial era would have
lasted a lot longer
maybe another fifty years it would have
come to an end because people don't like
to be ruled by other people particularly
but the end of the Imperial era was as
much a self-destruction of Europe as it
was a victory of liberation it was in
exhaustion after two world wars and the
rise of Bolshevism as a as another path
so by 1950 at the end of World War two
the politics of conquest was put into
reverse because Europe was too exhausted
to maintain its empires the diffusion of
ideas and technology had gone on far
enough that it became possible for this
phase of catching-up to start taking
hold and japan had invented the model of
catching up all asian success in my view
was the japan success repeated in
several variants japan invented techni
technological catching up how do you
imitate the leader how do you leapfrog
how do you reverse engineer and did it
magnificently and then help spread that
in a variety of ways to Korea Taiwan
partly through the legacy of empire in a
peculiar and subtle way and then through
direct investments in Malaysia and
Thailand and so forth and then all that
example became the main example for
China in the opening under dong shell
ping in 1978 and that was absolutely
fundamental because China represents one
third of Asia's population and India in
a similar way another roughly one third
and this process is in my opinion often
running very very deeply and and
irreversibly except for global disaster
so I believe that what we're seeing is
the end of the period of widening and
now we're in the catching up phase which
is natural and the technological leaders
are not so far ahead technologically of
the technological followers anymore
that the engine of new innovation keeps
the spread widening and in any event the
diffusion of good ideas now is so fast
that even if the United States were the
lab
Laboratory of innovation us innovations
would quickly spread to the rest of the
world and not lead to this persistent
widening that technological innovation
in the 19th century did well this is all
every word I've said is contestable
obviously this is all hunch but if it's
true it's pretty significant because it
really means a deep reshaping of the
world of the meaning of the west of the
meaning of the rich in the poor
countries of the developed in the
developing world and of the relative
power of the United States which i think
is bound to diminish tremendously not
because of a collapse of the US but
simply because a rise of other powers
and so that's the relative concept and I
think that it's a pretty much a likely
phenomenon and as far as I'm concerned
fine because it basically means the
spread of prosperity to more parts of
the world so one way to think about this
is in terms of GNP shares and this is an
attempt using the data by Angus Madison
who's our great macro historian who
makes GNP accounts over centuries of
what this means for Asia the West and
that is not a Fria africa and latin
america and the idea here is using a
simple convergence model to allow for
catching-up growth to take place so the
pork grow faster than the rich but as
they get richer they slow down so they
don't overtake the rich they just
converge with the rich that's the way
this model works if you let it run
forever everybody ends up with the same
level of income in the quote long-run ok
that's how the mathematical assumptions
work and the thing that I'm interested
in is mainly the Asian you Asia was more
than
50% of the world economy from most of
modern history because Asia has been
home to about two-thirds of the world's
population for his for 2,000 years as
far as we know and everybody used to be
poor before 1800 so the share of the
world's population was just the share of
the world's GNP in a region was roughly
its share of population there weren't
big discrepancies of who was rich and
who was poor then came the Industrial
Revolution and a place with small
population could have a big share of
income and so what happened was the West
became dominant and that's these bars
here obviously the the red bars and the
share of Asia in the world economy fell
from 60% to 20% and the share of Asia
and geopolitics fell from 60% to 20% if
I could put it that way in naive terms
and now this process is reversing as we
see every day like the African leaders
telling the European leaders at the
summit yesterday sorry we're dealing
with China now they didn't quite put it
that way they said still give us aid but
we are also dealing with China now but
you could tell the whole flavor of the
relationship of Africa and Europe has
changed because there's another another
party in the negotiations now and so the
idea that Europe can just dictate the
following terms is passe and that's what
Europe is finding because they're
interested in having geopolitical
influence in Europe in Africa they used
to just be able to demand it but now
they can't demand it because there's
competition from China and increasingly
from India as well so the African
governments are saying sorry we don't
want to negotiate this kind of treaty
with you and we'll do this our way and
we'll do this this way
it's interesting change of politics and
if you project Asia becomes again more
than 50% of the world's population now
on this model by the way Africa and
Latin America the yellow bar rises
significantly Africa is I don't know
maybe 2% of the world's GNP right now
and about 13% of the world's population
what's very interesting demographically
is that Africa will be more than 20% of
the world's population soon that in and
of itself is a remarkable phenomenon but
if there is economic catching up in
Africa also Africa all of a sudden
becomes a much more significant player
geopolitically as well
seems strange in a way but it's but it's
actually I think quite likely so these
are the change of GNP and this is just
to say if you run this kind of model
mechanically out right now measuring GNP
s in so-called purchasing power parity
adjusted dollars that's using
international prices to value all the
different economies at the same set of
prices the US is roughly twice the size
of the Chinese economy right now a
little bit more than twice the size
actually so the u.s. is about a 14
trillion dollar economy China's about a
6 trillion dollar economy that's in per
capita terms the gaps much wider because
China is also four times the population
so that means about 1/8 the per capita
income level but with China's rapid
growth by 2025 China will probably be a
larger economy than the United States
and by 2050 India will be a larger
economy than the United States not in
per-person terms but in total one of the
reasons by the way is India's pie
halation is continuing to increase in a
mind-boggling amount in absolute terms
by 2050 India is expected to have a
population of 1.6 billion it's 1 billion
today I don't know if you've been to New
Delhi it's awfully crowded and if you've
been to the countryside in India it's
awfully crowded it doesn't feel like the
countryside anywhere and the population
is going to add oh another 600 million
people so there are a lot of question
marks on this but the point is that this
is of fundamental geopolitical
significance so let me say just a few
more words about the demography the
oddest thing in development is that the
rich have few children they can afford
them and they choose to have few and the
poor have lots of children and can't
afford to raise them and this is a can
be rationalized as a individually
rational strategy for households under
different conditions of returns to
children individual investments in
children and mortality risk in poor
settings with high mortality risk it
pays to have lots of children and invest
less in each one whereas in
circumstances of low mortality risk of
children it pays to have a few children
invest very heavily in them that's one
kind of interpretation of this
phenomenon but it leads to the odd point
that however you slice it the poorest
places in the world are experiencing the
largest population increases by far
that's a big problem when we come to the
failed States because these places have
already demonstrated that they're having
a very hard time with technological
catching up and higher populations in
general do not make that easier doesn't
make it easier for two reasons one is
that a poor family cannot afford to
invest in
six children with proper education for
each of them so the children end up
under educated undernourished under
tended in health terms and therefore
poor when they grow up so you replicate
poverty and second the rise of
population is putting tremendous
ecological stresses on what are very
fragile ecosystems so the highest
fertility rates in the world are in
Africa in tropical Africa that's just
missing data but it's actually would be
read the same way in the Democratic
Republic of Congo basically fertility
rates above six that's kind of a mess
from an economic development point of
view having six children maybe two of
them do not survive so a woman will have
four children surviving to adulthood and
two of those on average will be girls
so each mother will be raising two
mothers to adulthood and that's the easy
way to realize that a fertility rate of
around six means that the population
doubles every generation so on average
you have a doubling of the population
every 25 years that's a lot that's
really hard to keep ahead of as a
development economist I can tell you
because you're trying to help figure out
what's a pathway for Africa out of
poverty and then oh by the way there
will be twice as many people in 25 years
to that you have to look after to raise
for the schools for the clinics for the
water for the farms for the jobs and so
this is a major major problem but it's a
fundamental shaper of the world this is
a an attempt I mean it's a heuristic
attempt only not a real forecast but a
an attempt of the United Nations
Population division to give a long-term
forecast for three hundred years
it's basically running out a model that
allows for all places to reach the
replacement fertility rate which is too
children are a little over two children
one of them being a daughter each mother
having one daughter raised to adulthood
running it out to the Year 2300 and what
you're seeing in the top level it's a
very I don't know why I don't have color
here what you're seeing in the top is
Africa's population projection so Africa
had not so many people in 1950 what is
that these are billions so maybe that's
250 million and by now Africa has 800
million people and by 2050 Africa 1.8
billion people on this forecast so think
about how the world is changing
tremendously now the part that is
relatively diminishing in all of this is
Europe where the fertility rates have
gone below replacement rate and the
populations are now - are expected to
decline in absolute terms in the US were
at replacement rate and in migration so
the u.s. population is expected to rise
from 300 million to 400 million up to
the year 2050 keeping the US share of
the world population pretty much
constant Africa share rises Europe share
Falls tremendously so Europe's
geopolitical role will definitely
diminish also but could be quite a nice
life you have all those wonderful places
fewer people fewer crowds and in fact
the if you run the demographic model for
Italy which has 60 million people now if
you run it to 2,300 Italy has the lowest
fertility rate the whole world because
they're not listening to the Pope it
seems
so if you run ATF our so-called total
fertility rate of 1.2 which is each
mother raising 0.6 of a daughter or each
ten mothers having six daughters on
average you could see it populations
going to tend to go down turns out that
by the Year 2300 there are only 600,000
Italians in this forecast and everyone
has a giant estate again they all have
their own vineyards each one can have a
you know a hill town for themselves but
that's the that's the implication of the
demographics and it does mean a pretty
significant change of structure actually
China because of its one-child policy
also diminishes is share of the world
population still is large but instead of
being I as it is now 22 percent of the
world's population it ends up being
something like 16 percent of the world's
population Africa as I said rises to
about a quarter of the world's
population that's only forty five years
from now that's a huge change that's not
a marginal little change that's a huge
change in the kind of world that you're
going to be living in and leading and so
we really need to take these shapers of
of that change quite seriously one of
the things that I find impressive in all
of this is a comparison of what's
happened between Europe and the Islamic
world because I have a kind of
demographic theory or I think demography
has been under emphasized in thinking
about this 1,000 year conflict between
Christian Europe and the Islamic North
Africa the Middle East and and and Asia
Minor because one thing that isn't
recognized usually the way the story is
told is that West that Europe beat the
crap out of the Ottoman Empire if you'll
excuse the phrase because of superior
institutions that's the story we tell
and by the late 19th century that
certainly it's not institutions it's
superior military power but what's quite
interesting is how the Ottoman Empire
was a really a long time serious rival
for with Europe up until at least the
end of the 17th the end of the 18th
century certainly the end of the 17th
century and then the 18th century it
lost but a huge difference a huge change
was simply demographic which is that
Europe experienced the tremendous growth
of population starting around 1500 the
food supply increased tremendously
settlement of northern Europe multiplied
and the end the Islamic population
pretty much stuck in the drylands of
North Africa in the Middle East had very
little population increase and so the
gap of the European population and the
Islamic population widened tremendously
and I think that this was probably the
fundamental underpinning of the shifting
power between the West as it were and
the Islamic countries which had a lot of
other advantages but finally lost out in
sheer numbers now what I find
interesting is that with the rise of
modern technology ability to import food
against oil Healthcare many other things
the right the Islamic population has
absolutely soared out of sight and it is
just now reaching parity with the
European population and by 2050 will
outnumber Europe and I believe that this
is part of the geopolitical change
underway in the relative balance of
power between Europe and its Islamic
neighbourhood and I think this is being
severely felt in Europe right now and I
think it's a real trend and change
that is a reflection of this deeper
underlying demographic shift here's the
ratio of the population of at least as I
have been able to measure it from
various atlases of global population the
ratio of the Islamic to Christian
population started out about one at the
beginning of the Islamic Age and then it
fell to 20% by 1800 and got taken over
by the West the whole region was
colonized by the West and it led to a
certain amount of unhappiness I would
say manifested in a kind of no thank you
get out of our region right now which
somehow the word didn't get to the White
House in time but it was really a very
bad adventure to think that Baghdad
would welcome us as conquerors and now
it's gone back up and it's going to
exceed parity and so this is almost
never remarked it needs more serious
study than I'm giving it but I do think
that the demography is really a deep
shaper of the changing power right now
between the two regions and this is just
counting males 15 to 29 you can guess
why it might do that because that who's
fighting and the interestingly in 1950
when we toppled 53 when we toppled the
government in Iran for example there
just weren't that many young males in
the Middle East compared to the number
of young males in Europe but now there
are more young males in the Middle East
than there are in Europe and the young
males in Europe actually don't want to
go fight in the Middle East also so
that's an amplifying effect and the
young males in the Middle East are
better at fighting than they were before
also and so this is why I think the age
of empire is definitively over as well
and all these fantasy
the US as the sole superpower and
striding the world like Rome and the
last Empire and all of this I think is
just pure mythology and I don't know
what they were smoking when they said it
or drinking but that's what they were
doing they were doing something they
were drunk on power and other things
probably one other point that I think is
worth very much bearing in mind is that
in a global society our internal
population structures change also to
reflect more of the world and this of
course is the profound angst of the
Republican Party
maybe the saving grace of our age they
can't tell whether they want to win
power or hate other people more and so
they're deeply divided on how to handle
the immigration issue the party is
basically founded on hate or a certain
part of it of people that are not like
us and on the other hand they need their
votes and so they don't quite know which
debates to show up to and how to answer
and who to kick out of the country and
so on
and what's interesting is that the u.s.
is of course becoming more like the rest
of the world ethnically racially
demographically and by the year 2050
according to the census 50% of the u.s.
will be non-white so that's a huge
change that is I should say non-hispanic
non-white so Hispanic black Asian other
ethnicities will be 50% of the
population white non-hispanic 50% and
this is of course look at the profound
change from nineteen
when it was about 77 or 78 percent white
non-hispanic it will be 50% white
non-hispanic by 2050 and interestingly
of course the Hispanic proportion is the
largest proportion these are projections
that have all of the risks attached to
them but it was Karl Rove strategy to
his credit that he was the pro-immigrant
conceptualize er of the permanent
Republican majority because this is one
where Bush has been on the open quote
liberal side because the idea was to
court the Hispanic vote because they
could read the same tables these tables
they did read apparently from the Census
Bureau but they couldn't get their own
party to agree to it because the party
was founded on quite different
principles which was it was a party of
just us to put it in quotation marks and
so that's a deep division right now that
is changing US politics but I think the
fundamental point is this demographics
is really about the internal structure
as well as about the international and
the same thing could end up being true
in Europe as well where the different
fertility rates of the Islamic
populations in Europe with a much more
hypothetical sense of the in migration
from North Africa Turkey and other
Islamic countries has led some
demographers to suggest that by the year
2050 I the Muslim population could be
between a fourth and the fifth of the
European population and in major
European cities 40 or 50 percent and
we're seeing also the tremendous
stresses on society and on politics
where this is probably the number one
hot button issue in European politics
now or almost surely is the number one
issue in in politics so I think that
this is another may
your point of of globalization okay I'm
done with half my talk so I'm going to
accelerate and try to spend five minutes
on the last two to two points all of
this economic growth is weighing very
heavily on the physical environment the
growth could be shut down for three
kinds of reasons none of them very good
I mean none of them very fortunate one
obviously is war so everything I've said
is forecasting a continuation of peace
but we're not so good at avoiding global
war I think we better as Tom as the
songwriter Tom Lehrer once said if we're
going to study World War three we better
study it now because we won't have the
chance to study it afterwards so one
thing that could go wrong is global war
a second thing is deep economic collapse
globally we've had one Great Depression
in two hundred years and it came because
of World War only because of World War
so I don't think it's in the cards but
it's not impossible and the third thing
that could go wrong is ecological damage
so severe that it undermines the very
ability of the world to continue to
achieve this kind of economic
development that it aspires to and here
the basic point is that the number of
areas dimensions in which we're really
messing with the Earth's physical
systems is significant right now it's
not just climate it's land
it's the nitrogen cycle it's a invasive
species it's a diversion of water
supplies it's the depletion of ocean
fisheries and so we've got very very
serious stressors in the world and all
of them relate to the global Commons all
of them relate to the parts not easily
governed by localities or generally by
the parts even even that can be governed
by nations and that means global
cooperation needed to solve them and so
far very low levels of it I'm not going
to talk about climate change more except
I'll say one one more thing about it if
you look deeply at the issues of climate
change or water scarcity or biodiversity
loss here's what I find in a nutshell I
find first that the current trends are
just terribly dangerous terrible second
that diverting from those current trends
would not cost a lot so I find the
paradox that the current trajectory is
worse than you think more dangerous than
you think and at the same time solving
it is less costly than you fear and that
I think is a great paradox which is that
those who say don't worry about it are
absolutely wrong
those who say worry about it because
it's going to destroy our society as we
know it are also wrong the truth I
believe is actually both inconvenient
and convenient if we look at it
inconvenient in that it's really bad
what's happening but convenient in the
sense that we are not without ways to
address it and the reason is that we're
in a were in the predicament we are
because of our Sapir
your technology and because of our
superior technology we also have
powerful tools to address the problems
so we've gotten into it because of our
carelessness and because market
institutions can't solve these problems
on their own because the signals are all
wrong yet the very technology that has
led us down this dangerous path suggests
closed kinds of technologies that are
much much better so I don't think
there's anything hopeless in it but it
comes back to where I said I was going
to end and that is politics it comes
back to politics because it's not
impossible to find a solution to those
problems it's just that we have to agree
to do it it's not something like a a
good film where you make it because you
think you're going to be able to succeed
in the market takes over it's something
we actually have to agree on to try to
do and agreement is politics
and we haven't agreed on these things
yet final thing I want to say is about
war and peace and actually I've said a
lot about war and peace there are two
kinds of problems of war and peace that
I think are quite distinct one kind is
war between the great powers because
they drive each other crazy
competing for preeminence and that's the
world war one kind of war where Germany
triggered a war because was sure that
Russia and Britain would never allow for
German technological dominance and so
they launched a preemptive strike before
they would be encircled so that's the
kind of war that one could imagine one
true cross-border war and that's the one
we started Iraq
so this is a map I kept data kept by
sipper II the top line is civil
conflicts and the bottom line is
interstate conflicts and this is the
point that I'm making most of the war we
face is the top kind of course we we
just need one of these to end the world
if it's between the major powers but
these have been kept quite low and it's
the state's falling apart
or under great stress that are the
biggest problem now one thing that I
believe to be the case is that these
different categories of problems of
environmental stress demographics
poverty and conflict are all
interconnected in crucial ways and that
most of these civil conflicts have a big
footprint of all three of those factors
poverty demography and ecology playing a
role so I view the Darfur crisis for
example which has been called arguably
the and arguably correctly the world's
worst humanitarian crisis I view that as
an ecological crisis because it takes
place in an extremely dry part of the
world that got a lot drier in the last
50 years because of climate change a
demographic crisis because the
population in Darfur went from 2 million
to 6 million people in the last 50 years
and a poverty crisis because nobody can
figure out how to make a livelihood a
sustainable livelihood in Darfur because
it is a remote interior parched arid
environmentally degraded home of semi
nomadic pastoralists
and impoverished subsistence farmers and
nobody earns any income so I view that
conflict is basically a rupture
of society that happens when the
situation is so extreme this is not how
it's usually viewed it's usually viewed
as a war some people view it as a war of
Arabs against Africans some people view
it as a war of Khartoum against Darfur
which is the western part of Sudan but I
think all of those miss the underlying
point which is that this is just an
impoverished region facing more and more
stress so here's a map of showing in
shaded areas the so-called dryland
regions places where there's not enough
water year-round to keep soil moisture
and it ranges from sheer deserts to
what's called the dry subhuman and the
sites of the world's conflict violent
conflicts it's not a perfect fit by any
means about half of the conflicts now
are in the drylands the other half in
places with plenty of water it's not
meant to be a mana causal explanation
but it's a disproportionate risk factor
and I believe that if we're going to get
to the root causes of the conflicts we
have to get to the root causes of the
environment that this junjin weed is is
riding over politics has given him an
ak47 state politics with the Libya Chad
Khartoum and so forth but the
desperation is the physical environment
where maybe his ethnic group came from
the north of Sudan 20 years ago because
of the prolonged droughts to try to find
a new point of settlement in the south
and there is no open land that way
certainly not open land with water and
so there's been a war of ethnicities
since then which Khartoum ended up
siding with the with these with the
pastoralists so finally choice
this is where politics comes in and very
complicated
I've given you some if they're not even
scenarios but I've talked about
fundamental drivers the fundamental
driver of convergence the fundamental
driver of population momentum the
fundamental driver of environmental
stress and the fundamental driver of
failed states in the physically most
challenged places in the world the
drylands or tropical rainforests with
the miserable soils or landlocked
mountainous countries afghanistan
pakistan i the andean region very tough
places for economic development what are
the scenarios possible to build from
this i believe that there is a scenario
of not only peaceful coexistence if i
could put it that way but actually
spreading prosperity the end of extreme
poverty the stabilization of the world's
population at eight billion and the
solution to climate change that i think
is not a utopian proposition that's just
a set of pragmatic choices none of them
cost very much that i'm an economist so
i look at the price tag if that required
30 percent of our GNP i want to know
what to do but my but by my count to get
those things right would cost about two
and a half percent of GNP a preposterous
lee small number because we could help
the poor escape the poverty trap
contraception and family planning is
really low cost compared to raising six
children in the desert or compared to
the war the results and climate change i
believe can be faced and greenhouse
gases stabilized for under one percent
of world income so none of it seems very
frightening in terms of
the allocation of resources the problem
I believe the interesting problem is
once you've done the technical analysis
it all comes down to politics how can we
make decisions collectively it doesn't
mean mean only state politics by
politics I mean collective choice not
only the operation of state power and I
think that this is really the big
interesting question because also
collective choice doesn't operate only
through state institutions never did but
much less now than it used to so if you
think about how to actually address
these problems it does involve business
it involves civil society it involves
government it involves international
organizations and treaties and there's
no conductor of the process certainly
there's no one locus of responsibility
or authority and the United States is
not will not be the leader of this
process it's too late in the day for
that we're only 5% of the world's
population we are perhaps 1819 percent
of the world's income now that will go
down to maybe 12 percent we got too many
other things on our mind this is not
1945 and US dominance so we're going to
need to find a way for collective
decision-making for things like this
very complicated process underway in
Bali under the UN Framework Convention
on Climate Change to be successful
that's a hundred ninety signatories
negotiating but what's also interesting
is today the Nobel Prize of Al Gore was
shared with the Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change which is a body of a
thousand scientists from all over the
world who are able to get their act
together to write a wonderful
report which clarified the scientific
consensus on this highly complex topic
so that's a unique in my view unique
kind of global process that IPCC of
mobilizing rigorous science for the sake
of public policy on a global scale so
it's a new kind of institution and I
think we need new kinds of global
institutions that also move beyond
normal politics if we're going to pull
off the kind of global cooperation that
needs to be achieved
finally I'm an optimist I don't know how
but we're going to have to do this and I
like to end these days with the
quotation from a great optimist who
inspires me to read and listen to when
that's President John Kennedy who gave
what I regard as the greatest speech of
a modern American president in the
American University commencement June
10th 1963 and what's interesting about
this speech is that it was in the shadow
of an even more frightening time the
Cuban Missile Crisis and the world had
nearly blown itself to smithereens and
Kennedy felt this issue of choice more
than ever because also he saw that most
of his visors would have gotten the
whole world killed if he had listened to
the generals advice because everybody
wanted to bomb and so this is a speech
directed to the American people to
basically urge them to give peace a
chance and to have some hope in the
ability to solve problems and it's such
a clever speech because it's about the
problems of peace with the Soviet Union
but he almost doesn't say a word about
what the Soviet Union should do only
about what the United States should do
to make peace so
like George Bush giving a speech about
Iran saying let's figure out how we
should change our views constructively
so we can make peace with Iran well I'm
not holding my breath although I really
like to see it but that's the speech
Kennedy made and so I just want to read
you two things that I think are very
important to think about in terms of the
global problem-solving he said first
examine our attitude towards peace
itself too many of us think it is
impossible
too many think it is unreal but that is
a dangerous defeatist belief it leads to
the conclusion that war is inevitable
that mankind is doomed that we are
gripped by forces we cannot control
we need not accept that view our
problems are man-made therefore they can
be solved by man and man can be as big
as he wants no problem of human destiny
is beyond human beings man's reason and
spirit have often solved the seemingly
unsolvable and we believe they can do it
again I am NOT referring to the absolute
infinite concept of universal peace and
goodwill of which some fantasies and
fanatics dream I do not deny the value
of hopes and dreams but we merely invite
discouragement and incredulity by making
that our only an immediate goal let us
focus instead on a more practical more
attainable peace based not on a sudden
revolution in human nature but on a
gradual evolution in human institutions
on a series of concrete actions and
effective agreements which are in the
interest of all concerned there is no
single simple key to this peace no grand
or magic formula to be adopted by one or
two powers genuine peace must be the
product of many nations the sum of many
acts
it must be dynamic not static changing
to meet the challenge of each new
generation for peace is a process a way
of solving problems many wrote what I
think are the finest lines of
speech and of the modern presidency so
let us not be blind to our differences
but let us also direct attention to our
common interests and the means by which
those differences can be resolved and if
we cannot end now our differences at
least we can help make the world safe
for diversity for in the final analysis
our most basic common link is that we
all inhabit this small planet we all
breathe the same air we all cherish our
children's futures and we are all mortal
thank you very much
yeah I know but what have we done lately
yep yep so the the idea of the
millennium villages is to go to a region
utterly impoverished and believe me
think about the poorest place you know
and then divide by ten think about a
place that has one physical brick
structure in a square mile it's almost
unimaginable adobe walls thatch grooves
no clinic no safe water no road no
transport I'm thinking of mbola one of
our villages salary is not absolutely as
extreme but is extraordinarily
impoverished and then ask what's the
difference of this and viability so the
idea is basically that these are
impoverished subsistence or what we call
sub subsistence communities that can't
even generate sufficient productivity to
stay alive reliably much less to have
development and situations been getting
worse in these places the basic economic
theory is the theory of the poverty
trap which is that if you're so poor
that you can't generate your basic needs
you also can't save if you can't save
you can't get out of your trap and in
fact you can't even hold your current
ground because you're depleting your
environmental resources maybe cutting
the trees or depleting the soils and
typically as is true in all our village
sites the number of children is rising
very fast also there's no contraception
there's no family planning and because
the poor choose a lot of children also
when they see such high levels of death
of the children so all of this is truly
unsustainable the theory of the poverty
trap is that you can convert from an
unsustainable downward spiral to a
sustainable upward spiral if you can
raise the productivity above the
subsistence level because if you can do
that then there's a margin for saving
then all the good things that can happen
oh then they invested in microfinance
then they added to cows then they built
a road then they added a roof then they
brought electricity and all those normal
parts of positive development can take
hold so there's a dividing point in this
logic which is on one side of the divide
you go down and on the other side you go
up and mathematically there's a dividing
point where and that's the nature of a
poverty trap if this is right that
there's a threshold if you can invest
beyond the threshold then it's not a
matter of continuing the investment then
the normal processes can take hold so
the investments we're trying to make our
improving the soil nutrition building
long-lasting clinics schools bringing in
electricity which is a one-time
investment but then stays there
afterwards paving a road to connect the
village bringing in microfinance units
and learning that's a kind of human
capital investment so that we leave at
the end of five years but those things
stay the we don't we're not going to
take the clinic back with us
and we're not taking the school back
with us and we're not taking the
powerlines back with us we're not taking
the road back with us we're not taking
the nitrogen in the soil back with us
we're not taking the nursery in which
they've diversified the crops back with
us all of that stays we go that's the
theory what is the there are several so
the general point that is made nine
times out of ten
oh that's just giving them money but
once they leave you know it all falls
apart that's happened a thousand times
before is a misunderstanding
it's just bad economics and I wish those
people would call me to discuss it
before they write these articles because
they waste your time frankly so at least
he could have discussed the concept but
he didn't even know the concept because
they think it's more interesting to
attack them to place a phone call which
is a little odd okay that's academia it
is so what are the real issues here the
real issues our first is it really true
that you can invest above the threshold
so is it really true that there are
viable things for this community to do
issue number one you know maybe it's
just such a godforsaken place it's
impossible okay
that's issue number one issue number two
can you do it in five years that's a
good issue issue number three do you
know what you're doing so even if there
is something and you could do it in five
years have you made the right diagnosis
together with the community issue number
four is managerial sustainability
because no matter even if you put the
road in and the power grid and the
farming you need actually to sustain
those investments not the financial or
the resource cost but you know being
able to fix it if it breaks down for
example so and then is political
sustainability there has to be a
political structure that the village
doesn't go to war with itself
that it's able to govern the
interventions and finally this has to be
environmentally smart if it's five years
of further depleting the environment but
it's based on tapping groundwater that's
just going to disappear and we go away
and then the drug the well dries up
that's also bad so they're about six
definitions of sustainability that are
valid it's not easy to do this but it's
not like we don't think about it morning
noon and night it's not a new concept
it's actually the core of the concept or
it's not the courts the second part the
core is raising productivity and it's
the insight that you know a bed net and
a bag of fertilizer and actually
wireless internet and a cheap computer
that these things are now available as
powerful technologies and then you can
have powerful technologies that people
don't use because they're too poor to
adopt them you need that mindset you
need to be able to understand that
people can be watching their children
die know that they need a bed net and
yet can't afford it that's the truth I
don't care how many critics say
otherwise I know that's true because I
see it with my own eyes and I'm trying
to convey that and then studies come out
and they say oh that's true they
couldn't afford to buy it but there's
actually even a faster way you look and
you can learn some of these things but I
admit it's not as scientific but it is
actually that's not even true it is
scientific to look carefully and to
record and to describe it's just not
counted the same way and it's got to be
measurable and replicable so the core
concept is you can raise productivity
and then the second is now finally on
the under governance we deal every day
with the district officials not we'd the
villagers there there we don't have
anyone there we're just advising the
villagers they're the ones living there
and local people that are directing the
project ok so they deal all the time
with the villagers we can't take a step
in the clinic for example without it
being approved by
the district health officer because this
clinic is not an NGO clinic it's a
Ministry of Health Clinic in every
single millenium village that's a point
of principle we can't do the road the
power anything just because we have the
money everything is with the local
government so the article got it
completely wrong in terms of the
substance of that it that this was a
mystery it got it right in asking some
questions which are the questions that
need to be grappled with and frankly
five years is a very quick period for
this transformation if the donors were
you know easygoing and here's another
billion item a to ten years but we are
in such a difficult world of mobilizing
resources that we went to the limit of
the resources we can mobilize and we
think that it's a close call but an
achievable call to do this in five years
but it's not automatic it's just that
the naive way of that this is attacked
oh that's fine but that's just not
sustainable misunderstands that this
question of sustainability is at the
absolute center of the logic the
motivation the strategy the tactics
whether we make it we'll see please
to economies and they have to subsidize
their farmers at the end I mean end of
courtly sounds sounds great politics
yeah so the question was the general
principle of opening up to trade is fine
but in practice a Europe for example
continues to subsidize its farmers keep
its markets closed and in the end
politics will undermine the end of
poverty so good idea but it ain't going
to happen because of the politics if I
could put the gist of the question this
is a very complicated subject so let me
say just a couple of things about it
specifically about agriculture first
truly surprisingly most of Africa's
problems most of the poor world's
problems are not about trade barriers
that they face just is not true and if
it were true I'd be the first to want to
say it I'd have no hesitation in saying
it but it just isn't true if I thought
the way to get Africa's needs met was
through liberalisation of European
markets I'd spend my time on that I
actually decided not to spend very much
time on that not because I thought it
even because I thought politically it
was hard I just didn't think it was that
strategic a way to to proceed why do I
say that because we actually have a
pretty open world economy right now for
most things the fact that very poor
countries in most African countries
export only a small number of items oil
gas gold copper coffee cocoa tea sisal
you know maybe eight or nine come on or
maybe eight or nine commodities diamonds
the reason that you have a small number
is that Africa is not competitive in the
rest of the million items the
can be traded they just can't trade it
they can't produce and trade it and
that's true of almost all manufacturers
and one way that I think is important to
see that is that during this last 25
years China went from 20 billion dollars
a year of exports in 1980 to 800 billion
dollars of exports this past year in the
same world market environment that
Africa did no increase of manufactured
exports to speak of and Africa did not
face any more barriers than China it's
just the China was competitive Africa
was not why in my view the main reason
is that China had roads electricity and
a number of other features whereas
Africa did not and there's a lot of
history which I try to describe in the
end of poverty about why the environment
is different why the history has been
different and what to do about it but in
the end of the day I feel that the
problems of competitiveness are not
trade barriers so much as the capital
stock whether it's of salary village or
the capital stock of Kenya if you've
been on the main road of Kenya from
Mombasa to Nairobi to kusuma it's a one
road for millions and millions of people
it's the highway to the port but it's a
two-lane pockmarked impassable road much
of the year you just can't believe a
country would depend on it
they're so poor they can't get that
thing built and sustained and if I were
you know what if I were I am advising
the World Bank mainly as a pest I tell
them all the time first thing they'll
help them build a proper highway because
until you do that you can't get viable
manufacturing going because the
transport costs are so high you actually
can't sell the goods and I went in
Uganda with President Museveni a couple
of years ago to the four
or textile exporters China has tens of
thousands Dhaka Bangladesh has thousands
of textile exporters Uganda has four
apparel exporters in Kampala and I went
to each CEO said what's your problem the
road because that's a landlocked country
on the same road to Mombasa but they
can't transport so they can barely stay
alive we went to a textile mill with the
Development Minister of Tanzania a few
months ago what did the Trent the
Planning Minister asked the CEO what's
your big problem
the Road Minister so it's basic
infrastructure now there are a few
commodities that are really nasty in the
policies cotton being the number one and
that's the one always held out there and
it's horrible
my god we've got 26 styles 26,000 cotton
farmers in the u.s. pulling in three
billion dollars of subsidies what a
racket talk about corruption it's
disgusting and it depresses the cotton
price of Mali and Tanzania and Kenya and
so forth but it is not the real issue of
development it's terrible I want to end
it but you it's important to reflect why
have you heard the cotton story 50 times
because there aren't ten good stories
there aren't even five good stories so
what we really need to do is get Rhodes
power and and then finally one last
point on the real guts of the Doha round
negotiations in agriculture the issues
are not about Africa the issues about
Argentina Brazil Chile the US Canada
Europe South Korea Japan Australia New
Zealand why because the issues are about
cereals they're about wheat they're
about rice they're about soybeans
they're about
a little bit about maize but they're
basically about staple exporters which
are the mid to high latitude countries
with lots of land not the African
tropical savanna so that's the you know
okay I won't say more okay people who
need to go go and then as long as you're
willing we'll take another Oh anyone can
go any time but let's do five more
minutes and then we'll wrap it up okay
please and speak speak up please for
everybody yes yeah well I think
demographics affects the number of
soldiers in the field and that is has
been important and I think it's actually
important now in this strange way in the
shifting balance in the mid between the
Middle East and Europe
I don't think demographics is I when I
basically think what's important for
demographics because I don't think we
should have population policies geared
towards making soldiers for war I think
the main issue about demographics now is
the the issues of environmental
degradation and extreme poverty those I
think are the most important demographic
issues I what I was saying is that I do
think that the relative numbers of
population will change and that will
change to within some margin politics
within countries and even geopolitics
Africa will loom larger with 20% of the
world's population than with ten
but if I were Africa I try to stabilize
at 17 or 18 percent thank you very much
because the issues of
vironment and poverty are really the
predominant issues that count in this
and small can be beautiful in quality of
life none of this is about quality of
life terms of quality of life you know
stay a stable population and a leaving
some margin of land and nature is it
definitely conducive to quality of life
so I didn't want to imply any sense of
desirability of a population boom as a
way to solve a geopolitical problem
quite the opposite I think it's a very
poor way to try to mobilize power the
dominant finding is that these
population bulges of large population
growth and high fertility are
destabilizing rather than stabilizing
and they work against economic
development also yes speak very loud so
everyone can hear you so how could more
Aid get into the hands of the extremely
poor the main way is very practical
interventions of things and commodities
directed at local needs bed nets
medicines fertilizer high-yield seeds
clinic construction and keep the experts
let experts go as volunteers on their
spare time not on our taxpayer budget if
you had to allocate much less technical
assistance and much more commodity
support that's what I would recommend of
course I'm not recommending keeping the
aid budget where it is right now because
we're spending actually I was going to
show you a picture that's our foreign
policy in the United States you know
it's a lousy way to build security
and even secretary gates our defense
minister our Secretary of Defense said
in Kansas City last month and I brought
a quote hold on
what is clear to me is that there is a
need for a dramatic increase in spending
on the civilian instruments of national
security
diplomacy strategic communications
foreign assistance civic action and
economic construction and development
said Secretary Robert Gates good for him
now I am well aware that having a
sitting Secretary of Defense travel
halfway across the country to make a
pitch to increase the budget of other
agencies might fit into the category of
Man Bites Dog or for some back in the
Pentagon blasphemy it is certainly not
an easy sell politically and don't get
me wrong
oops I'll be asking for yet more money
for defense I didn't read that move
how awful we don't need more money for
defense we do not need more money for
defense believe me we don't you know why
because this pictures one you're out of
date when sip reproduces the next
picture the United States will be
spending as much as all the rest of the
world combined on the military that's
too much so mr. gates we don't need more
for defense but you are right we need
more for diplomacy and development so we
shouldn't settle for the existing level
we have and I want people to understand
that our total aid to Africa is 5
billion dollars a year
our total Christmas bonus on Wall Street
last year was 24 billion dollars a year
24 billion of the Wall Street Christmas
bonus I'll show you one more thing
one more bit of magic two days Pentagon
spending is 3.4 billion dollars we're
spending 1.1 million dollars a minute in
the pentagon 1.1 million a minute okay
so for two days Pentagon spending we
could have comprehensive malaria control
in Africa because it that requires three
billion a year now Africa needs 300
million bed nets to fight malaria each
bed net costs $5 that's one point five
billion dollars needed for comprehensive
coverage of every sleeping site in
Africa with an anti malaria bed net five
years they last five years okay drum
roll 21 hours of Pentagon spending would
get you five years of comprehensive anti
malaria bed net coverage Oh God
it's amazing it's amazing we can't get
this done it is just the weirdest thing
I don't know what they put in the water
supply in Washington but truly this
makes no sense from a national security
point of view a foreign policy point of
view a public health point of view so
this is really about choices and that's
why we shouldn't settle for this meager
amount that we give right now for every
hundred dollars of US GNP how much do we
give to Africa in aid for every hundred
dollars the answer would be four cents
for the poorest eight hundred million
people on the planet this cannot be good
for our security thanks very much
you